[Music]
so a florida man
with drugs found around his penis around
the penis yes swears that they are not
his drugs
who put it there wait is there is there
drugs around his penis along with saliva
marks
you are [ __ ] csi right now holy [ __ ]
dude so good those are the questions we
should be asking you yeah they did they
did not talk about saliva marks there's
nothing about slaving you should have
been a forensic scientist man
i don't know if it was like
hey what's up dad
you know this [ __ ] coke answer that's
true that's the forensic scientist he's
the detective on the scene he's like
was it
that's true because like you see a ring
of crack that was really good if you see
a ring of crack around the dick the
criminal came in this way that was
cracked lipstick what i would like to
know
what i would like to know um and it
doesn't say that obviously they never
have good reporters who ask the right
questions
um they they this is a routine traffic
stop why were they searching around his
penis
wait
did it just say it's around his penises
and like it's just on his crotch
or like was he like
on the circumference of his
dick skin read this for me
wrapped around a man's penis during a
traffic stop wrapped around can i tell
you something so one of our cop friends
um he says that criminals are actually
really bad at being criminals most thank
goodness because they could catch them
we can look at it let's go and go if i
pulled this car over right now
i'll be able to find something on they
just give so many clues so like this i'm
so good he's like i have so much
evidence in my pockets i could sprinkle
it who i pull over it's like a [ __ ]
i'm [ __ ] houdini
but he's like yeah i can just tell the
way this guy's tags are his lights are
whatever the way he's driving i'm sure i
could probably find maybe a small nine
millimeter probably
hidden under the seat i'm sure there's
some like a brick of like weed over here
like
he's like just statistically so they're
profiling people yes exactly interesting
like they're playing poker though it's
like a 77 chance 50 chance 65 percent
chance like is it worth the pull over um
i don't know it's like we searched uh
officer researches his his entire car
there's nothing and he's like was the
raptor on his
penis he also told us that uh he rides
this detective suv that has a scanner
that's constantly going off while he's
driving and then it's scanning all the
plates around the road and then so like
if a plate that has a warrant on the
driver shows up he knows like oh you
know that's someone with the warrant
that's something with the warrant that's
something if you can't find anything
else it's gonna be around the penis or
the butthole
how do you plant drugs on someone's
penis i mean nick you're probably the
most qualified person to tell us i'm
glad you asked thank you and i will tell
you tell my master class no show me
touch me they get a sour strip
and then lace it with crack through the
little hole and then they wrap it around
their dick oh that'd be good yeah
did they like pull this dude out the car
and like give him the feelings and stuff
to check you know it really doesn't say
it says that the uh that sounds like
that's likely like you're just touching
someone you're like why does it feel
like there's something here
that's my sour strip and it's always
based on how bad your answer is like if
you say something really stupid then
they're like we're gonna that's or if he
steps out of the car it's like crunch
crunch crunch like why is it crunching
between the legs there's nothing there
sir
that's some cereal officer just some
cereal just put on my crotch so it's
wrapped around his dick right you guys
ever seen that video of the guy he's a
cop and he has somebody he pulled over a
guy and he's searching him and he's in
his pocket and he's like what is this
he's like my penis
and he's like yanking on he's like oh
[ __ ] my bad sorry dude but he's pulling
on his dick and he's like
what is that do you think anything do
you think an asian guy would get away
with saying that or he'd be like oh no
it's not
if it's really warm that's something
it's really warm yeah he's all night
that's a little fatty right there it is
that's a little steep green that's true
he's like what is this it's my dick
i'm like these were growers the
authorities found cocaine and meth
around his penis
is it in bags quite the combo i'm
guessing it's in bags or is it just like
a powdered doughnut yeah it's a sour
strip
they put it through the whole this looks
like a beignet yeah it's a baby
this ball sacks just dipped in powder
[ __ ] powdered sugar doughnut dude
just like a [ __ ] cafe dumont criminal
yeah just came from the french quarter
man it's all right
so yeah the deputies say they stopped
the vehicle driving without its lights
on 4 am see sketch criminals so sketchy
highly believe in that [ __ ] like you
literally don't know how to hide and
they just i don't know is that why is
that bad why is it bad like profiling
[ __ ] works a lot of times that's kind
of what doctors do right like oh you got
a fever maybe you're sick well it's just
like you can predict these outcomes
like don't say that profiling profiling
[ __ ] works
profiling is is why is profiling bad i
think profiling works because that's
what doctors do too profiling [ __ ]
works randomly all right profiling steve
you don't know me you see me okay what
do you think about me i mean you're a
little [ __ ]
and it works
i feel like you don't like police hey
now take the hat off
like it's all i got
this guy thank you that is good
mechanics profile right a [ __ ] toyota
comes in and they're like god damn it i
can't make no money i'm not saying
racial profiling i think general
profiling yeah it's pretty [ __ ]
effective like driving around at
i gotta say it's not the racial
profiling because when they're look when
the cops are looking for wait wait hold
on
when the cops are looking for a good
time
and they see a car full of minorities
then you know they're looking they're
trying to have fun right
but then
when they're trying to do their job and
protect the good american people
then they're not racial profiling
they're just trying to protect and serve
and i think it's like a car thing too
like if you if they give you no cars and
you like cars you [ __ ] profile the
time based on someone's car i don't even
know what race they are but i definitely
know a lot of other [ __ ] about them yep
like what they say about guys with big
ass trucks like they're just [ __ ]
lifted to the sky that's profiling make
fun of like the truck nuts that's
profile drug nuts are sick though but i
think everyone in this world should be
created equal regardless of
anything
sorry why don't i believe him at all
because of his hat
it's because we know him on and off
camera you know why is because i
actually believe this side more treat
everybody like a criminal is that what
that side does
no no no
treat everybody like a mental health
patient and have no police
to pull them over do you know have you
ever heard of the whole thing with the
israel israel's airport and their the
israeli uh basically like the forces
that um like the security at the airport
of israel they [ __ ] get bomb threats
every day
but their whole thing isn't about like
they make fun of the tsa's process
because the tsa just treats everybody
like they're like this [ __ ] old lady
could be have a bomb and they just
[ __ ] laugh at that because they're
like no you got a [ __ ] profile you're
wasting a lot of time but the tsa does
that so they could be equal yeah but
that's the thing like my [ __ ]
six-year-old niece might have a bomb
what is this gel yeah right i bet it's
[ __ ] crazy
am i lighting it i'm like dude
she have a bunch of jealous hate to my
[ __ ] show dude
yeah dude
if you profile someone's behavior that's
not bad well that's like they're being
sketch you know trained in this way of
detecting based on tiny nuances about
people yeah because they're not doing
all brown people right it's exactly
because that wouldn't [ __ ] work yeah
right it's more like if someone's
scratching himself over and over it's
like you fit the description buddy
there's like a tiny like subtlety you
can read in people to see like whether
they feel like they're nervous about
something like little slight forehead
sweat the slice shifting around looking
around checking in upper corners to see
security cameras like why would you need
to look at the security cameras yeah
little ticking sounds yeah ticking
sounds in your bag
trail of white dust falling out
yeah just [ __ ] like that so you guys
don't look at security cameras when you
go into stores or anything like that i
actually do well dude you know like when
you go to like a 7-eleven and they had
that [ __ ] screen that's bigger than
[ __ ] and it's like right in the front of
the store almost basically saying we're
watching you i immediately look at it
because i'm like whoa and then look at
the guy and i'm like i'm like damn dude
yo look at it start dancing oh [ __ ] all
i have to do
i only look at it if i'm going to
scratch my nuts
or i'm just going to see someone look at
me scratch my nuts i scratch like this
yeah or i pick my nose i do that do you
guys watch this show on youtube called
gas station encounters so you were just
talking about you were watching this at
your home the guy that works at the gas
station he works at gas station uh
somewhere in like i don't know i don't
know where it is wichita but yeah he
basically profiles people the same way i
mean like you kind of just get used to
it when you do this job right a pattern
yeah yeah so he sees people come in they
usually always look at the teller see if
they're distracted right then they go
down the aisles and they always seem to
think that corners are pretty good spots
so like slip something in your pocket
even though they have a camera like
right on your [ __ ] ass they have all
the blind spots yeah it's great though
it's great he catches people like
shoplifting at a store and then at the
end of the video he's always like please
tell this person to turn themselves in
for stealing a snickers bar and [ __ ] i
think if you do anything enough you just
pick up patterns like even going to the
dog park if i see the person like come
out and he's already on his phone i'm
like oh this is the kind of guy that
doesn't pick up his dog [ __ ] yep you
know he's just there just to let the dog
out or you see a guy come out and the
dog's already like going crazy you're
like oh this is the kind of guy who has
a dog that's going to fight other dogs
because he's not well socialized you
just see like all these little patterns
that's really in depth
i don't do anything like that dude
you're a [ __ ] computer
you're a [ __ ] terminator 2 robot i
bet you that when you drive you you
could tell when certain people are like
oh this guy he doesn't drive he sold his
car yeah i don't drive i don't have a
car sold for crypto
i guess
everybody everybody does you probably
see someone's crypto wallet and go oh i
bet
you got anything with anu in it i'm like
dude you're uh you're gonna get wrecked
anything with eating i don't have any
more
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you